[Music]
what's up guys umhd here 755 product
launches later we've made it through
techtober took a little breath
and now we're right back at it with
november and it just keeps going and
i've started my november with this this
is the iphone 10r
and this one already has a bit of a
reputation but ideally with my testing
and hopefully in this review we can look
past that little reputation
and figure out what this phone really is
i mean it's another iphone and i already
reviewed the iphone the 10s so i'll
leave that link to the review below
but this one is very similar in a lot of
ways with the new parts in the new
design but with some key differences so
for this video let's look at everything
that's different about the iphone 10r
that adds up to 250 dollars cheaper
and what i think of it okay so first
things first is the size the iphone 10r
sits right in between the 10s and the
10s max with this 6.1 inch display it's
fine i'm one of those people who wishes
there was an even smaller iphone so the
difference was more apparent but this
6.1 inch display kind of splits the
middle it's definitely harder for most
people to reach the corners and the tops
of this display because it is so big
that's one of those things though that
you can check out just by getting in a
store and seeing for yourself but this
size for me is fine
and then the build the iphone 10r is
made from different materials and it's
built differently than the 10s even with
pretty much the same looking design
there's no stainless steel here iphone
10r has anodized aluminum sides which
means they can color match them to get
it to match the glass backs and yes
there are the six new colors and i know
i've said before the red is my favorite
and yes it still is but i'm going to go
ahead and give my second place to this
blue i really like it i think it's quite
nice the coral on the yellow don't
really speak to me as much i think
mostly because of the rail colors being
a little less saturated
and the black and the white are just
black and white so the red and the blue
are definitely my two favorite 10r
colors also small difference the iphone
10rs water resistance is ip67 where the
iphone 10s was ip68 so worth noting and
you'll also notice the slightly
different locations for the antenna
bands the 10r is missing a couple just a
pair of visible bands that are on the
10s and the 10r since it lacks these
bands does not have gigabit lte this
only affects a tiny number of people who
are actually in an area where their
carrier supports gigabit lte but hey
it's different so there you have it
overall i'm mostly a fan of the build of
the 10r i think the colors are awesome
they didn't have to do colors so i'm
glad they did
the backs with the glass are super
saturated and bright and vibrant but the
aluminum on all the colors on the rails
is always less saturated than the glass
which makes sense but it's kind of a
bummer if you put a case or a skin on it
because then you hide the awesome color
of the glass and you just get the metal
it's not the end of the world but just
had to point that out also with the
aluminum it's even more slippery than
the stainless steel this is i think the
new slipperiest phone in the world champ
prone to sliding out of your pockets if
you're not careful so be careful okay so
the display this is the biggest
difference versus the iphone 10s this is
why apple was able to make this phone
that cost 250 less this is why this
phone even has a reputation already
before people even get to use it this is
the most controversial part of this
phone iphone 10r has what apple calls a
liquid retina display you can ignore the
fancy name but it's an lcd with curved
corners
it's 1792 by 828 and it's surrounded by
this slightly thicker bezel
the panel itself it has great color and
brightness pretty good viewing angles
and believe it or not it's actually
crisp enough for me at regular use
though i do start to see it as less
sharp than the 10s when i pixel peep
from close up but it's really not a bad
display by any means it's accurate it's
vibrant it feels like the easiest way to
make the iphone 10rs display seem bad is
to focus entirely on the numbers of it
don't even look at the display just look
at the spec sheet and the numbers on
paper it's less than 1080p
and it's 326 pixels per inch that's the
pixel density you know what else has
that pixel density the iphone 4.
that's an easy way to make it look bad
but you know it also has a pixel density
of 326 pixels per inch
the iphone 8
and that was fine most people didn't
complain about that and that was a great
display so really focusing on the
numbers isn't the most productive thing
just look at well the actual experience
of using this phone and looking at the
display and in practice the biggest
losses for me with the 10r display are
no 3d touch and no oled apple did bring
touch to wake to the 10r so you don't
lose that but obviously contrast in the
black when you're watching a video isn't
quite the same with an lcd and even
though this is one of the best lcds
you're not going to have the pitch black
7 oled i personally didn't use 3d touch
that much anyway pretty much only in the
control center and the lock screen so on
the 10r you can do almost the same thing
with a long press that will work in the
control center and on the lock screen
shortcuts but you can't peek and pop
into links and previews and things like
that that's almost completely gone from
the 10r but i honestly don't miss it
that much you still have true tone so if
you're into that i don't really use true
tone but if you do it's also here and
you have tap to wake like i said you
have rounded corners
it's fine the display no need to panic
it's really fine as a matter of fact
what i really noticed the most isn't the
resolution it isn't the lack of 3d touch
it's the bezels these bezels all the way
around here just a couple millimeters
thicker than the iphone 10s are
noticeable to me every day and to be
fair after a little while you do get
used to it but as a person that has used
an iphone 10s i much prefer that it
looks and feels that much more modern to
shave i guess one or two millimeters all
the way around the bezel
so sure it's a bummer that you can't
watch full 1080p videos especially on
this larger display trust me 1440 does
look a lot better i would know and it's
a downgrade to lcd and there's no 3d
touch but the bezels to me are actually
the most consistently noticeable
difference that you'll have and you'll
have to be okay with them if you're
going to rock this phone all right two
quick ones the ram and the battery both
of these are kind of a side effect of
them going with the lower resolution
display first of all there is one gig
less of ram so three gigs of ram instead
of four but honestly that's kind of all
you need in ios when you're pushing way
less pixels and ram management is
already great and then the battery the
iphone 10r has a
2942 milliamp hour battery and it's
really good now for most phones that
statement wouldn't really line up but
again because that a12 bionic is so
powerful and it's pushing way less
pixels the iphone 10rs battery life is
excellent just as good as the 10s max
and sometimes better it's one of the
best parts of this phone of course i
would expect a phone this big to have
all-day battery life just out of
principle but having it be better than i
expected was a pleasant surprise so that
leaves the biggest difference
the camera the single camera on the back
of the iphone 10r which is the exact
same as the primary camera on the 10s
minus the second telephoto some people
have noticed uh slightly different image
quality from the 10rs camera versus the
10s i have not for me it's still the
same a very good iphone camera
but subtracting that telephoto lens has
actually had some interesting
implications that aren't all negative so
that telephoto camera as you know is
good for two things
optical zoom and portrait mode so
optical zoom yeah that's gone you can
see a worse quality digital zoom but
here's a little not so secret secret
about zoom on the iphone that telephoto
lens has always been a worst quality
sensor and image that just let in less
light so oftentimes in worse conditions
specifically low light the iphone will
realize that the optical zoom
coming from the darker lens is actually
not as good as the primary so it'll just
take the digital zoom from the primary
lens anyway so yeah there is no
telephoto lens on the iphone 10r but i
think that affects a lot less zoom
scenarios than we actually realize and
oftentimes we're going to get better
results from using the better camera and
then the other thing is portrait mode so
the 10s would use both cameras for depth
detection and then use the telephoto
camera to zoom in for a better natural
bokeh the 10r portrait mode obviously
doesn't do this which means it's always
using the better quality primary camera
and it's a wider angle and i don't know
if you've noticed but uh wider angle
portraits with a shallow depth of field
is kind of my favorite look it's kind of
a thing i think it's the most visually
interesting version of a portrait so i
kind of really like this they've
remapped the background blur to look
more like a wide angle optic than
telephoto and it makes a real difference
through all the bokeh adjustment i
really do notice it the background feels
kind of more swirly sometimes like they
have more character but there is of
course a downside which is that it
doesn't have depth detection anymore at
all so it's doing pretty much all of the
work with software and with that apple
has limited it to photos of human faces
only so if you try to take a portrait
mode of anything else it won't work
it'll tell you it's kind of waiting for
a person to be detected so that's kind
of a bummer no portrait shots of objects
which i've started doing more on plenty
of other android phones but that's the
price you pay in apple's world so all
those previous points have added up to
the iphone 10r starting at 750 bucks for
64 gigs
definitely not a budget phone don't let
anyone tell you it's a budget phone but
at
cheaper than the iphone 10s
this is a much better deal the biggest
downsides are the display and the camera
i know a lot of things i kind of spoke
about on the camera were pretty positive
but don't let me fool you into thinking
it's a better camera those are the
biggest downsides of this phone but
those are when comparing it to the
iphone 10s but a lot of people are
coming from iphone 8 and iphone 7 and
older and for those people this is an
upgrade in pretty much every possible
way and for not much more money the
iphone 8 started for 700 bucks this is
750. so my conclusion is pretty much the
same as i suspected when this phone
first got announced which is this is the
best seller iphone for everyone they
didn't even have to do colors imagine if
they just did a black and white iphone
10r a little more boring probably would
have flown more under the radar
but the fact that they did the colors is
kind of like a cherry on top so if
you're one of those people who was
already gonna get an iphone 10s or 10s
max you probably still should just like
i said in the review it's not like you
should switch to this instead of that
but if you're on one of those older
phones iphone 10r
is a good upgrade i recommend it there's
nothing to panic about nothing crazy
wrong with it
thumbs up for me on this phone that's
been it thanks for watching talk to you
in the next one
peace